you know when things go terribly wrong
and a crime-scene cleanup is needed the
Mafia calls in the cleaner the one who
disposes of the body after the hit or
covers up the evidence after the crime
now in the movie Pulp Fiction the
cleaner brought in to dispose of the
corpse is Harvey Keitel when covert
missions go wrong the government calls
in its own cleaner and when things go
terribly wrong for the Democrats they
don't just call in a cleaner to get the
job done they call in someone who's been
in the cleanup business for a long time
they call in the serial cleaner former
FBI director and now special counsel Bob
Muller now the latest details this week
of a continuing cover-up by the Trump
hating deep State as if we needed
further proof that Donald Trump was
being framed was evidence that Bruce or
the fourth highest ranking DOJ official
back channels forbidden information to
the Department of Justice so after
Christopher Steele is terminated by the
FBI or ignores his own rules of his
department and he meets with steel to
peddle his fraudulent dossier to justice
the intent clearly to tee up a Special
Counsel investigation and the amazing
thing is that Bruce or had absolutely
nothing to do with Trump Russia
collusion investigation yet after Donald
Trump gets elected he inserts himself
into Trump work Russia to get steel in
on the Muller team Bob aren't you
embarrassed by this whole fiasco around
you you actually have a 70 year old man
Paul Manafort put in solitary
confinement 23 hours a day on a 2007 tax
case having nothing to do with Donald
Trump or Russia
Woojin because you're trying to get him
to rat on the President of the United
States and you're panicking now bub
because Donald Trump's legal team
doesn't want him to talk to your team of
Trump haters I mean come on everybody on
your teammates the president but what I
don't get Bob is how you can sit there
under the sanctimonious veil as if
you're a holier than now and not be
investigating the real crime that keeps
jumping out at you and us every week
why aren't you investigating James Comey
who lied before Congress or Peter struck
teed up a fake Russia collusion
investigation or Andrew McCabe and now
Bruce or and his wife Nellie his wife
had a job with a fusion GPS the group
that Hillary Clinton funneled her money
to to get to Christopher's steel to
create the fake dossier to make believe
Russia had dirt on Donald Trump in the
form of a sex tape so here we have Bruce
or who's not just violating the law
you're not even disclosing his wife is
working for the agency paying for the
dossier Bob are you stupid but your
credentials as a government serial
cleaner are really good they're etched
in the record he testified after four
Americans are killed in Benghazi to
cover for Hillary Clinton's in
incompetence Bob why would you say the
FBI couldn't get to Benghazi in time it
took two or three weeks they needed
someone who would say the FBI couldn't
get to Benghazi since it was way too
dangerous
Bob honestly you look and sound like a
fool CNN and just about every newspaper
in the country in the world got there
they made it there but the FBI couldn't
hey I get it a good cleaner Bob once the
crime scene is trampled as possible but
you know Bob we're all getting tired of
this and this all comes down to your
effort to get Donald Trump indicted and
you are panicking you got nothing and
talking a talk of subpoena him is rude
dick Ulis and Bob you should know better
just between the two of us when you were
subpoenaed in the whitey bulger disaster
in Boston and your Justice Department
argued that you were just too busy
fighting terrorism to talk about 1980s
Boston you fought that subpoena and
ironically you argued that the attorney
that was looking to subpoena you just
like you're looking to subpoena Donald
Trump didn't demonstrate why information
from you couldn't be gotten by other
means and now ain't that a hoot Bob when
you were the head of the FBI in at just
over 28,000 employees back then and you
claimed you were too busy to testify
well how about this
Donald Trump is too busy fighting the
fighting terrorism for over 320 million
Americans and protecting us and he
doesn't have time for you and your
nonsense subpoena either what's good for
the goose is good for the gander and
that's my open if you like my opens
you'll love my new book New York Times
number-one bestseller
liars leakers and liberals it's all in
there if you're fascinated by any of
this the case against the anti-trump
conspiracy